on this episode I talk about my next
book money and everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and you're watching the
askgaryvee show episode 14 fun fact on
the number 14 I am born on the 14th
November 14 and I have played the number
14 on roulette every single time that
the ball has rolled in my life we're
talking about 8,000 times ecaterina
wants to know what role does internal
culture play in the company's success
can you give one concrete tip on
building that culture you can Tarina how
are you doing it's always great to hear
from you I'm glad you're on the show uh
company culture is actually the oh no
it's funny it's funny this questions
coming up today I actually on the way to
work today said you know what the book
that I'm gonna write that's really gonna
like but you know I always think is
crush it who thank you economy's gonna
sneak up on people I know as I sit here
today the book that I write on culture
and how to build an organization through
humans not CFO cash tactics is going to
be my book legacy so whenever I get to
that so it's everything to me
as an operator I'm all EQ over IQ the
one concrete tactic I have is way too
many people make decisions on who they
fire or hire based on money oh we have
the budget to hire another designer or
camera person or like it's it's a
financial decision all my decisions on
hiring and firing are emotional what is
it going to do to the collective
community you know if I fire this person
who's so popular internally because they
have great people skills will that hurt
everybody else and can I can I push that
person into another direction help them
get another job over 90 days instead of
firing them abruptly in one day that
costs me a lot more money but does a
hell of a lot for me in the culture and
so that is my one concrete
kind of curveball I haven't heard a lot
of people talk about that kind of stuff
example hi Gary this is yella
from Amsterdam this is why I need to be
in episode 14 because our biggest dutch
soccer player called johan cruyff
we were the number 14 so it's really
important for us for our Dutchman and
here's my question Gary I've read a book
in 2011 called Think and Grow Rich by
Napoleon Hill and that book changed my
life in a very positive way I'm very
curious about you Gary did you read any
books that change your life in a very
positive way thanks big shout out to all
the Dutch veiniacs um the answer to this
question is pretty interesting this
gonna be one of the shorter answers the
answer's no
that pre mentioned book that I'm
planning on writing if it's my fourth or
fifth or sixth book when I hit eight
books uh writing I will accomplish a
very rare feat which is that will be the
moment where I've written more books
that I've read I believe that one of my
core weaknesses is my lack of reading
books I just don't read books it is
stuff I've read three business books in
my life if you call the Steve Jobs book
a business book uh John batali wrote a
book called search about Google and then
one my favorite book I've ever read was
called nain it was about the Supreme
Court I've read like seven bucks sorry
and Tori asks as I launched the shift in
paperback what were the three most
effective things you did to drive book
sales Tory thinks in a question really
was excited to put your uh your question
on on the show because I just really
want the maniacs to know about you I'm a
fan we've done some events together good
luck with the book without knowing the
true context of the book though and and
everybody will have to do their own
homework on that part there's a couple
secrets I have for everybody who wants
to write a book that have really worked
for me and they're not really secrets
actually quite boring my belief is that
you actually sell your book
a year two before you're actually
selling your book by providing by the
global Jab Jab Jab right hook here's an
example Tori I'm not keep selling my
fourth book right now I'm putting out a
show every day I'm taking time which is
my number one asset
I like time I like time more than money
I prefer time which had a watch over
cash that's how valuable it is and Here
I am taking time every day out to just
answer questions to provide value to
give value to entertain to give an
answer to make somebody think to provide
value in their entrepreneurial venture
to the people that have been me worth
their time thank you and so you know I'm
selling my fourth book right now because
I'm providing value to a whole new
audience as I'm in fact a quick question
of the day leave in the comments section
if you've discovered me because of
askgaryvee that'll be interesting to see
what happens to comments please do that
if you are don't be a lurker how many
use that term a long time um so that's
number one number two and this is a big
unknown thing to a lot of people it
surprises me how many people have not
figured this out
people don't want more content as much
as they want more access everybody wants
to do book offers where if you buy three
books you can get a free ebook or this
that more content right get into this
what they want is access one of the
biggest things that I did Tory that
really sold a lot of books for me was
give myself to the audience if you did
this many books or bought this many
books I would do this live stream Q&A I
would come to your school I would make a
video for happy birthday I would
literally skip sell the number one thing
people want from me which is more access
and it's the thing you want from
everybody that you appreciate you want
to spend more time with that person
those are two I'm giving you I'm not
giving you a third one because those are
the two that matter hey Gary this is Ian
westerman from essential tennis com I've
got a quick question for you for
askgaryvee first and foremost though
thank you so much for what you do it was
six years ago that I was commuting an
hour in each direction to a job back and
forth listening to crush it and that
book fired me up so
so my question for you is when you play
tennis or at if you're still playing
tennis now do you see parallels between
tennis and business and being successful
in either one or in both what what are
those I'd be really curious to hear your
thoughts great great question you know
what's really interesting to me
tennis is game I love a lot and I've
recently figured out how not good I am
because I've met a lot of private school
kids rich kids who play tennis a lot and
we're on the college tennis team and so
I love the game and I like playing the
people that give me good 6-4 7-6 6 to
kind of matches in both directions and I
have a lot of fun with and I like it a
lot and as a matter of fact I really do
see one parallel line I've never thought
about this before and this is really why
I love the askgaryvee show thing you
know I I do see a parallel I'm blown
away that I once lost a match that I was
winning 5-0 in a set and I'm also super
happy can somebody get Nate Zach can you
get Nate uh this is me fun I'm also
happy that you know and you've heard me
talk about halftime adjustments right on
the coach they'll be down 21 nothing and
then it's 23 21 and I won because I
didn't game playing well but I adjusted
that to me is tennis right to me tennis
is fascinating cuz the set is very long
and you can be down 3-0 and then you're
adjusting you're seeing patterns for
example you know Nate is it true is it
true that you've never beaten me in
tennis unfortunately yes now is it also
true that you once had me down for two
you've had me like help me here you've
had me down 5-2 twice right and you lost
those matches okay so what I did in
those matches were that was that thanks
bro so in those matches when I was down
five to two Nate what happened was you
know one I just like refused to lose but
two I really kind of took a step back
look that what happened in those first
seven games and started attacking either
weaknesses of his or strengths of mine
it's a very mental game I was reacting
to what was already happening in that
space
except and I was able to adjust in and
win 75 much to my happiness and so much
like in business people set out to do
things it's kind of like the Mike Tyson
quote right everybody's got a plan until
they get punched in the face you know
that's what I see in tennis and that's
what I see in business you have your
business plan you think you're going to
succeed and then you're out in the
market and somebody copies your product
for less or is better than you or nobody
really wanted your stupid app you've got
a just and in tennis because it's a set
it takes a lot of time for that that
kind of like set to like form and you
gotta just - wait a minute he's playing
off of his back here let me go up his
backhand things of that nature let me go
to the neck because I'm not winning this
baseline game the adjustments in real
time and the emotion and composure and
the intestinal fortitude to be down five
- and come back and win that's how I see
it tree wants to know what situations do
you find yourself most comfortable in
tre this is a great question you know I
loved it when Steve brought it up like
hey you wonder this question of course
this is like a humble brag question you
know uh you know I mean whoa where am I
most awesome you know listen the thing I
take most pride in is I'm probably be
probably best when it's chaotic and I
think a lot of people fold in that sense
but to me I take an enormous part what I
don't know is I'm really great in
chaotic non-threatening I'm being very
honest here because I don't I want to
disguise this humblebrag with a little
humility because of how I like to roll
you know I uh I'm great in business when
we're real trouble like I'm great that's
my world I'm really good when people are
upset you know like a kid in my class
died in a car accident senior year and
like I like I was proud in the way I
helped a lot of people I'm really strong
emotionally what I'm not sure about is
if like somebody came up and punched my
wife in the face like what would I do
like you know I'm such a lover not a
fighter that I always question myself in
that moment I actually think I come out
guns blazing but that's never really
happened but I'm most comfortable in
chaos as a matter of fact and people can
tell you this in the office
these guys can mention it and you see
this stuff I'm like rolling mic ringing
it's Chuck I hate quiet and standard I
like walking to vaynermedia everybody's
got their headphones on I can somebody
play some music like all this is like
way not enough for me my wife actually
like it keeps making fun of me because
the other day I somehow said something
like New York's too slow for me she's
like shut you know like like I am best
when there's a crap load going on my
friends I really appreciate you watching
the show the question of the day is
quite simple where is your favorite
vacation spot I'm trying to get into the
insight of you guys I'm also trying to
figure out on a tape an episode with
maybe one of you you keep asking
questions I will continue to try to
answer them
you